je m'appelle Sarah j'ai 12 ans je suis
Sarah et je vais répondre à vos
commentaires très intelligentes jeunes
filles j'espère qu'elle mène une vie
heureuse une heureuse vie dans
l'ensemble je suis une belle vie j'ai
une famille merveilleuse et des gens qui
m'aiment autour de moi et puis ceux qui
m'aiment pas c'est pas grave
heureusement que les mentalités ont
changé car moi-même à l'époque je l'ai
subi et personne m'attendu la main je
suis désolé pour vous que vous n'ayez
pas eu la chance d'avoir quelqu'un qui
ait pu vous écouter mais à l'époque moi
j'allais trouver qu'on avait été
bienveillant avec moi je l'ai pas mal
vécu à l'époque en tout cas quel dommage
que le harcèlement n'est pas été pris au
sérieux plutôt les périodes et des
époques n'étaient pas les mêmes et c'est
incomparable ce que je pouvais vivre à
mon époque et ce qui peut être vécu par
des enfants aujourd'hui mais on sait que
les enfants entre sont méchants elle
était une fille très mature pour son âge
bravo à elle c'était mission a été
importante pour moi de le faire pour
dire oh je suis là je suis un être
humain comme je le dis et je vous dis
que ça va pas elle a beaucoup de courage
pour garder confiance en elle mais oui
je reste confiante sur la la beauté
humaine surtout